at a hospital in modesto california the
price for a routine knee replacement
surgery might be about sixteen thousand
dollars
or fifty three thousand dollars or even
eighty one thousand dollars
how is a hospital able to charge such an
extreme range of prices for the same
surgery
the vast price differences are driven in
part by the secret rates hospitals
negotiate with health insurers for
everything from an mri to open heart
surgery it depends on the leverage that
the hospital has it depends on the
leverage the insurer has depends on sort
of who's good at negotiating and until
recently those rates tended to be secret
but they're not so secret anymore thanks
to federal rules that required hospitals
to make their prices public in 2021
sutter health is one of hundreds of
hospital systems now revealing their
negotiated rates
people didn't know what their
competitors were paying
and that limited the negotiations in
some ways so how exactly are these rates
set
here's what goes into the secret price
negotiations between hospitals and
insurance companies
to understand how u.s hospitals set
their prices let's take a look at
publicly available data from sutter
health's memorial medical center this
chart shows the prices for billing code
drg470
which is a routine hip or knee
replacement surgery the different price
tags depend on the insurance plan
covering the procedure if you look at
the lowest and most expensive rates you
can see there's a pricing spread of more
than 64 000
still the data doesn't represent the
full range of pricing the exact costs of
certain insurance plans are not
available on the hospital's website one
takeaway has definitely been the broad
range of prices that are paid for the
same service in the same hospital you
see this in sutter's data but you see it
across the board in lots of other
hospitals data so how do hospitals and
insurance companies come up with these
numbers hospitals typically have a
sticker price often called the charge
master rate this can be a starting point
for negotiations with insurance
companies at sutter health memorial the
charge master price for a routine hip or
knee replacement is set at 92 262
but there isn't an exact formula for how
this cost is calculated a lot of factors
influence charge master prices hospitals
typically will tweak them to meet their
financial targets the chargemaster rates
are not typically
really tied to
estimates of cost or value for the
service provided some hospitals are now
trying to drill down and say okay how
much does it really cost to do this
particular procedure but that's not
historically been the case insurers
would rather have rates that are not
actually tied to the charge master and
when they are negotiating more
successfully they're not paying a rate
that's a discount off the charge master
they're paying a rate set in some other
way hospitals will often tweak
chargemaster rates based on their own
financial targets then insurers will
often negotiate discounts off these
rates insurance companies tend to have
more leverage in the negotiations if
they can deliver a lot of patience if
they have a lot of market share in that
area and also if they're willing to
design a plan that has a limited number
of hospitals or a limited network so
that the hospital knows that its
competitors are not going to be in that
plan or not as favored as they are in
that case a hospital will tend to offer
a better rate insurers are essentially
buying in bulk using their large
membership to get better deals meanwhile
prestigious or large hospital systems
could have greater leverage in
negotiations
what gives a hospital leverage or
negotiating clout is basically being a
must-have system meaning that the
insurer really needs to have that
hospital system to have a good plan that
will attract customers in the markets
where sutter health has hospitals i
think it would probably be difficult for
an insurer to create a strong network
that included no sutter health
facilities they have some important
facilities and they are a powerful
presence in their markets in a statement
a spokesperson from sutter health said
it is the insurance companies not the
health systems who hold leverage in
these negotiations sutter negotiates on
behalf of our patients to help ensure
they can receive access to the
clinicians and facilities who can meet
their health care needs
meanwhile insurance companies have
generally said their contract
negotiations with hospitals achieve
large overall savings for their members
and comparing individual prices is not
indicative of cost competitiveness
the full impact of the contracts between
hospitals and insurers can be difficult
to see directly because the details of
the negotiations often remain secret for
instance some contracts include
restrictive provisions sometimes called
anti-steering clauses these clauses can
prevent insurers from directing patients
to less expensive or better quality
hospitals and doctors
hospitals when they have a lot of
leverage and are very powerful in their
market they can sometimes
win favorable contract terms so they
could get provisions in contracts that
said an insurer can't exclude their
hospitals from any of its plans that all
of its plans must include that hospital
systems facilities insurance plans
offered under government programs like
medicare and medicaid tend to get the
lowest rates because they're tied to
prices mandated by federal and state
agencies you can see this in the knee
and hip replacement surgery prices we
showed you earlier so you'll see that
all of the medicare plans are clustered
around exactly that same number because
it is related to what medicare itself
pays for that service but then you'll
see a big range of prices you'll see
some around fifty three thousand dollars
you see one as high as around eighty one
thousand dollars and those are the
negotiated rates that the different
insurers are paying because medicaid and
medicare plans tend to get lower rates
some hospitals say they need to rely on
the higher paying privately insured
patients for their revenue there was a
study that looked at more than 2 800
hospitals over 10 years and they found
that hospitals that boosted their
margins didn't cut their costs they
actually improved their revenue by
raising the rates they charged to
private insurers a spokesperson from
sutter health said the rates paid by
medicaid and medicare plans generally
don't cover the costs of care
the prices health insurance companies
negotiate affect consumers directly
through out-of-pocket charges like
deductibles and indirectly by pushing up
premiums for health coverage for
instance high deductible plans can leave
patients responsible for thousands of
dollars in costs before their coverage
kicks in total spending on private
health insurance in the u.s has
increased by about 40 percent over the
past decade according to federal figures
patients who don't have any insurance at
all can sometimes be asked to pay a cash
price that is higher than what insurers
pay it varies but some of these patients
may also if they are low income get
financial assistance in which case they
get discounts based on that or may have
the whole bill for given despite the
federal rules requiring hospitals to
make their prices public some hospitals
still haven't fully revealed their rates
on july 1st the second phase of the
federal pricing transparency effort took
effect health insurers now have to
reveal the prices they pay to all health
care providers
not just hospitals but also doctor
groups surgery centers and labs when the
federal government created these rules
one of the ideas was to help people shop
for services that's one question will
people look at these prices and try to
shop for care based on them the belief
is that now that those prices are
becoming more transparent we'll see a
narrower range of prices because
insurers and hospitals both will say hey
i see that other person's getting a
better rate i want that rate and that
will tend to narrow the big variation
[Music]